Я ось щойно був на вулиці, я щойно їв піцу, я говорив з перехожим. Це нормальне життя.
Ти не бачиш солдатів, військові літаки не літають у небі, і тут відсутнє будь-що, що пахне як війна чи небезпека.
І посольства все одно висилають свої родини.
Німець Єнс Десслер, який живе у Києві, говорить про рішення посольств чотирьох країн Заходу.
На тлі скупчення російських військ вздовж українського кордону посольства США, Британії, Німеччини й Австралії
вирішили евакуювати родини своїх дипломатів з України. МЗС низки країн також закликали своїх громадян
утриматися від поїздок до України і покинути країну тих, хто зараз тут перебуває.
Таке рішення спричинило хвилю паніки серед українців й іноземців, які стежать за ситуацією на українсько-російському кордоні.
Адже воно може вказувати на те, що ці країни очікують вторгнення Росії в Україну найближчим часом.
Однак не всі іноземці в Україні дослухаються до порад своїх урядів.
Наприклад, австралієць Кен Герберт каже, що виїжджати нікуди не збирається.
Мені телефонували з посольства вранці і питали, чи планую я поїхати? Я сказав, що ні. І вони…
Ну, я не думаю, що в них на таке була відповідь (сміється). Тому вони сказали, щоб я мав екстрений план, на випадок, якщо раптом щось трапиться.
Герберт переїхав до України кілька років тому, бо захотів пожити деінде, окрім СІднея.
У Києві він планував залишитися на кілька місяців і рушити далі.
Однак життя в Україні йому так сподобалося, що австралієць вирішив оселитися тут.
Київ - мій дім, так.
Моє життя тут. Я не бачу причин для виїзду, якщо Київ не потрапить під реальну фізичну загрозу.
На думку Герберта, серйозність ситуації перебільшена. Зокрема тому, що так її зображують в медіа.
Принаймні для нього ситуація, яку описують онлайн, і та, яку він бачить офлайн, значно відрізняються.
Зі мною контактували так багато моїх близьких і друзів з Австралії, які дуже хвилюються за мене.
Я читаю статті, які вони читають, і вони дуже різняться від того, що відбувається тут.
Є якийсь рівень хайпу, який з'явився у західних медіа, але це не та ситуація, яку я бачу тут.
Схожої думки і Єнс Десслер. Чоловік відкрив компанію у Києві три року тому, і зараз їхати нікуди не збирається.
А єдина зміна, яка відбулася в його житті останніми місяцями - він свідомо читає менше новин.
Друзі тут - вони налякані. Вони сприймають це більш серйозно. Можна, я скажу дещо?
Чим більше ти читаєш німецькі чи американські новини, тим більше ти наляканий. Тому ми вирішили -
ми мінімально це робимо, ми не слухаємо ці повторювані меседжі, бо це навіть не новини, це меседжі,
вони повторюються, повторюються, і тоді ти з'їжджаєш з глузду.
Американка Карі Одерман погоджується з тим, що паніку вона помічає більше серед іноземців або журналістів.
Але не українців. Однак вона має свою теорію, чому так відбувається.
Я  - така сама, як і всі. Щоб зрозуміти це, я маю сама пережити це. Найкраща аналогія - це гаряча ванна.
Люди з західних посольств, зі США, з Канади, вони ніколи не переживали конфлікт, не стикалися з такою ситуацією.
Коли ви потрапляєте до гарячої ванни вперше, ви кажете: "О, це гаряче!" -  і реагуєте на неї. Але українці сидять в цій ванні понад вісім років.
У своєму "ТікТоці" Одерман розповідає англiйською про ситуацію в Україні. Останнім часом її сторінка у соцмережі стала особливо популярною.
Наразі Одерман вирішила залишитися з родиною в Україні. Однак більшість її друзів-іноземців таки покинули країну.
Одерман визнає, що чимало людей в Україні негативно сприйняли рішення посольства США щодо родин дипломатів.
Мовляв, американці не тільки вистрибують з корабля, але і запускають ефект доміно -
інші посольства також будуть висилати своїх співробітників і їхні родини. Однак, на думку жінки, це може бути і позитивним кроком для України.
Але на це можна подивитися з іншого боку. Що США говорять: ми сприймаємо це всерйоз.
Цього не було минулого року навесні, коли Росія скупчувала свої війська на кордоні, я не думаю, що це було у 2014-му, хоча я тоді не жила тут.
Але коли США говорять: "Ми визнаємо невідворотність ситуації", це змушує Кремль блефувати.
Тим часом Єнс Десслер не так дипломатично ставиться до дій свого уряду. Він очікував від Німеччини більшої підтримки України.
Кореспондентка: А чи були ви розчаровані діями свого уряду?
"Дуже-дуже". Я був дуже розчарований тим, що керівництво зробило, а точніше тим, чого воно не зробило. Що не було потужного сигналу, що ми з вами.
Я розумію, що попередні політики - так, вони не були однієї думки щодо всього, але їхній основний посил - ти і я, ми разом, і це добре, ми рухаємося далі.
А тепер Аналлена Бербок вагається використовувати ці слова і бути чіткою, якою вона мала би бути.
ЄнсДесслер не вірить, що повномасштабне вторгнення Росії в Україну реальне.
Мовляв, інакше Путін не чекав би кілька місяців і не організовував би дипломатичні переговори з усім світом.
Данець Ронні намагається тверезо оцінювати ситуацію, попри численні перестороги й занепокоєння його рідних у Данії.
Чоловік уже сім років мешкає в Кременчуці. Одружений з українкою, має дітей, але не планує покидати Україну.
Більше того, він шукає можливості вступити до лав територіальної оборони.
Я знаю чимало людей, які працюють в армії. Я питав їх: "що ми маємо робити, якщо все буде погано тут, і як ми можемо допомогти?"
Я розумію, що я не буду бійцем. Але, можливо, їм знадобиться логістична підтримка, щось інше, чим я міг би допомогти. Тож чом би й ні?
У випадку, якщо Росія вторгнеться до України і захопить міста, Ронні планує евакуювати свою родину, однак сам він повернеться в Кременчук.
Це наш дім тепер. Це наша країна. 4:28 Якщо всі просто втечуть, то що буде наступним? Балтійські країни? Польща? Німеччина?
Та попри те, що іноземці, з якими поспілкувалася DW, наразі не пакують валізи, у кожного з них є свої червоні лінії.
У Карі, до прикладу, це критичні комунікації.
Інтернет, електрика, опалення. Це мої червоні лінії. І це щось, що ти одразу можеш відчути.
І справа не тільки в тому, що я боюся дискомфорту, але це моя відповідальність як мами.
А ось для австралійця Кена, як і для німця Єнса, червоні лінії - це захоплення Києва.
Минулого року ми святкували 30-річчя незалежної України. І ось на вулиці нашій було багато танків, було велике святкування, прямо під нашими вікнами.
Що мені дуже сподобалося, це коли люди стояли на вулиці і вітали солдатів.
Такого ти не бачиш більше в Німеччині.
І ось якщо будуть танки, але не з України, я думаю, це буде моя червона лінія.
На сьогодні іноземці сумніваються, що до такого дійде. Навіть якщо їхня думка різниться від офіційної позиції їхніх держав.